[Musique]
le costa rica est un petit pays
d'amérique centrale d'environ 51 mille
kilomètres carrés située entre la mer
des caraïbes et l'océan pacifique
totalement recouvert d'une forêt
tropicale humide de sa côte est à sa
côte ouest le costa rica abrite quelque
dix mille sortes de plantes 81 mille
espèces d'animaux dont des reptiles des
mammifères des amphibiens de nombreux
oiseaux et plusieurs types de poissons
champion du monde de la biodiversité ce
petit pays attire de nombreux touristes
pas moins de 2,7 millions de personnes
l'ont visité en 2016 cette activité
touristique liés à la biodiversité
suscite de nombreuses vocations et
génère des opportunités économiques
c'est le cas de gaëtan et sophie que
nous avons rencontrés dans le canton de
garabit tôt passionné de nature ils ont
débarqué il y a un an dans le petit
village de birague oil pour installer
leur gîte en plein coeur de la forêt
équatoriale et accueillir leurs premiers
clients
au premier plan des cabanons
le premier j'ai pour voir on avait déjà
demandé de remplacer quelque chose on
vérifie nous on a pris un terrain ici à
une demi-heure de tous et pour voir ce à
quoi ce paysage cette biodiversité ou
lever le matin vous prenez un café vous
avez des haras des toucans c'est à peu
près sympathique c'est vraiment génial
vous allez à une demi heure vous avez
des singes vous avez la mer ça a été un
cauchemar et si on peut le dire même le
temps c'est toujours beau chaud ça
agréable frais le matin frais le soir
c'est ce qu'il nous fallait donc on a
signé et on a embarqué et on nous voilà
aux costaricains
[Musique]
en attendant les premiers coups de
marteau pour lancer la construction des
chambres il faut commencer à constituer
un réseau et mettre en place une série
d'activités qui seront proposés aux
futurs touristes qui séjourneront chez
eux alors direction la rivière du thar
collège nous nous retrouvons josé
l'homme qui parlait aux crocodiles pour
sophie et gaëtan la réussite passe par
une bonne collaboration avec les
entrepreneurs locaux et créer des
partenariats devient une évidence c'est
ce qu'il tente de mettre en place avec
josé un costaricain qui vit bien de
l'écotourisme depuis de nombreuses
années dans la région du pacifique
central
son entreprise accueille environ 2000
touristes par mois en haute saison de
décembre à mai
bonjour je suis content de vous
rencontrer
je m'appelle sophie mon mari et moi
avons un projet touristique dans la
région et nous voudrions collaborer avec
vous afin de proposer des activités à
nos futurs clients c'est super est ce
que vous êtes déjà venu faire le tour
des crocodiles avec nous c'est important
de le faire si vous voulez le proposer à
vos clients venez je vous invite à le
faire maintenant voyez avec mon
assistante pour lui communiquer vos
informations
on veut se mêler à la masse on a envie
de partager notre vie au quotidien avec
les tic au et dans notre business aussi
on a envie de faire ça de faire
travailler l'économie un peu pour tout
le monde et donc du coup rocé locale il
connaît son enfant milieu mieux que
personne donc il n'ya pas meilleure
façon de lancer le projet quoi nous
allons remonter la rivière sur 7 km
ensuite nous allons aller en direction
de la mer vous allez pouvoir observer de
nombreuses oiseaux des iguanes des
poissons et bien sûr des crocodiles mais
attention à ne pas laisser traîner vos
bras hors du bateau vous pourriez
regretter
la remontée en bateau d'une partie du
thar coller ce s'effectue en une heure
trente environ il n'est pas rare de
croiser des petits groupes de touristes
en saison de pluie mais le clou du
spectacle reste sans conteste cette
rencontre avec le caracara à tête jaune
l'une des multiples espèces de rapaces
recensés et la proximité avec le roi de
la rivière le crocodile géant du costa
rica
ici au costa rica nous avons uniquement
deux saisons la saison de pluie et la
saison sèche la saison des pluies
correspond à la période nous avons le
moins de touristes du cours du mois de
mai à la mi décembre c'est en fait pour
nous la basse saison ensuite deux mi
décembre à mai c'est la haute saison
saison durant laquelle ma compagnie
enregistre environ 2000 touristes par
mois des visiteurs qui viennent de 15 à
20 endroits différents mais la plus
grande partie viennent des états unis et
du canada et par une majoritairement en
anglais et français
c'est un gros animal il pèse environ 500
kg et mesure pas loin de 5 mètres au
costa rica nous nous inquiétons de la
qualité de notre environnement nous
voulons le préserver en plus c'est un
moyen pour nous de gagner notre vie de
produire des revenus grâce aux touristes
dans les écoles tout est fait pour que
les jeunes prennent le relais on leur
enseigne aussi bien la conservation et
la protection de la nature dans le but
de préserver et d'améliorer ce que nous
avons cette belle forêt ses fleuves et
ses animaux
à
difficile de s'arracher de la
contemplation de cette faune riche
sauvage mais qui peut se faire docile
quand l'homme tente de l'apprivoiser
mais il faut repartir
direction la capitale sans procès à 120
km et deux heures de route à la
rencontre de ska ramirez professeur
biologiste à l'université nationale du
costa rica au delà des atouts naturels
exceptionnels du pays le positionnement
mondial du costa rica est un travail de
longue haleine construit avec les jeunes
générations de costa ricain à travers
des projets scolaires et éducatifs
le costa rica est idéalement placée en
amérique centrale cette position
géographique lui permet d'avoir une
biodiversité exceptionnelle provenant
des deux continents amérique du nord et
du sud
notre rôle est de comprendre et
d'étudier cette biodiversité
en tant que professeur universitaire
nous devons donner à nos étudiants les
outils pour qu'ils réussissent
pour ce faire nous leur donnons tout au
long de l'année différents projets
projets de gestion projet
d'investigation d'éducation des projets
pratiques qui leur permettront de mieux
comprendre l'importance de la
biodiversité
aujourd'hui il existe 27 parcs nationaux
dont deux font partie du patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco ainsi que 58 refuges
32 zones protégées 15 zones humides
marécageuse 11 réserves forestières et
lui réserve biologique qui complètent le
tableau autant de zones protégées qui
provoque parfois des contestations chez
certains autochtones qui estime que cela
modifie et altère leur tradition et
modes de vie ancestraux
diego va plus loin pour lui cette
politique de sueur protection de la
nature et hypocrite car les cultures et
les cours d'eau sont pollués à cause de
l'utilisation massive de pesticides en
tout genre rien n'est fait selon lui
pour favoriser une vraie culture bio
proche de ce que faisaient ses grands
parents
ma famille depuis des générations a
toujours vécu de la nature la forêt
était notre garde-manger nous cultivions
les terres nous chassions nous faisions
de l'élevage mais aujourd'hui à cause de
cette politique 100% préservation vient
beaucoup de lois les choses changent et
deviennent contraignantes nous ne
pouvons plus vivre comme avant
[Musique]
vous savez ce n'est pas facile il y a
trop d'interdictions trop de lois et
quand vous interdisez trop de choses eh
bien vous inciter les gens à passer dans
l'illégalité c'est la nature humaine on
en rigole mais cela n'a rien de risible
ici les choses sont extrêmement
difficile et dur il n'y a pas de travail
alors pour nourrir sa famille un chef de
famille doit aller à la chasse certains
gibiers peuvent te rapporter 80 à 100
dollars alors quand certaines personnes
qui te connaissent font appel à tes
services tu pars à la chasse et tu
t'assures des revenus qui t'aideront à
prendre soin détient
[Musique]
tu vois c'est un type de siph que nous
plantons et récoltons sans aucun
pesticide et produits chimiques c'est
100 % bio et naturels c'est ça la vraie
biodiversité
diego entend bien continuer ce combat à
peine audible pour le bien des habitants
du costa rica et pour l'image d'une
vraie biodiversité qui continuera
d'attirer des touristes
chaque année ils sont en augmentation de
près de 5% l'un des temps forts reste la
visite des nombreux sanctuaires dédiés à
la protection animale hier pour
comprendre le fonctionnement d'un de ces
refuges
nous nous sommes rendus au tout cannes
rescue center une structure de soins et
de réhabilitation qui recueille près de
300 animaux par an
nous avons beaucoup d'animaux dans le
refuge pour les nourrir nous leur
donnons environ 100 kilos de papaye par
semaine soit 15 kilos par jour mais nous
leur donnons aussi beaucoup de bananes
des carottes des brocolis des courgettes
des haricots verts et pour certains des
insectes vivent des centaines de kilos
de fruits et légumes pour nourrir
quotidiennement tous ces animaux et des
jeunes volontaires venus du monde entier
pour soutenir et s'occuper des
nombreuses tâches journalières de
l'association accueillir alimenter
nettoyer et soigner les pensionnaires du
centre qui souvent arrive à la suite
d'accidents causés par des voitures des
braconniers ou même une électrocution
[Musique]
par jour il nous arrive de recueillir de
1,5 animaux blessés donc en moyenne nous
recevons 30 animaux voire plus tous les
mois la majorité d'entre nous arrivent
suite à un accident souvent dues à
l'électrocution
[Musique]
quand nous le pouvons nous utilisons des
produits naturels tels que des pommades
cicatrisante à base de miel de caligula
d'aloe vera de plantes et de produits
venant du castor et k mais croyez moi
c'est vraiment efficace et nous permet
de soigner pratiquement tout type de
blessure
c'est entre les mains du docteur anna
maria et de ses assistants que les
patients du centre reprenne des forces
nourriture adaptée soins quotidiens
voilà le programme chargé de l'équipe
médicale objectif rétablir les animaux
blessés au plus vite afin qu'il recouvre
une meilleure santé pour qu'ils soient
relâchés dans leur habitat naturel
[Musique]
c'est important pour nous les
costaricains c'est bon pour le tourisme
pour l'économie notre petit pays est
connu dans le monde entier pour sa
biodiversité sa forêt ses fleuves ses
plages ses montagnes et tous ces animaux
c'est notre richesse et elles attirent
des touristes venant du monde entier
c'est donc vraiment important pour nous
de protéger notre nature exceptionnelle
après 58 ans d'une politique résolument
tourné vers la biodiversité et la
protection de la nature le costa rica
est devenu un exemple au niveau mondial
grâce à ses nombreuses actions et à des
investissements tant humains que
financiers le développement de
l'écotourisme prend alors tout son sens
signataire des accords de la coop 21 en
le costa rica souhaite aller plus loin
dans la protection de son environnement
en renforçant l'existant avec une
politique plus affirmée en matière
d'énergies renouvelables
et là il ne s'agit pas seulement de
préserver le costa rica mais bel et bien
de sauver la planète
on